well it seems like the spider-man Sony
Disney deal has come to an end
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
I wish I had better news for you today
but it appears that Sony Pictures CEO
Tony Vince acara has released an
official statement to Variety on
September 5th of 2019 which is today
sadly everybody hoping that spider-man
would remain in the MCU when we heard
from Sony Pictures themselves say for
the moment the door is closed stating
that there is no ongoing negotiations
contract or deal happening with Disney
currently so for the moment it is
official spider-man is no longer a part
of the MCU this of course is definitely
super upsetting news but fortunately for
us there is still a little bit of hope
quick reminder if you'd like a chance to
win an Xbox one or ps4 be sure to
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
giveaway the Sony CEO went on to say we
had a great run with Kevin Feige on
spider-man movies we tried to see if
there's a way to work it out the Marvel
people are terrific we have great
respect for them but on the other hand
we have some pretty terrific people of
our own Kevin didn't do all the work he
went on to say spider-man was fine
before the event movies did better with
the event movies and now that we have
our own universe he will play off the
other characters as well I think we're
pretty capable of doing what we have to
do here according to the Sony CEO the
reason for the breakdown is that Marvel
boss Kevin Feige has been stretched
incredibly thin with all of the new
characters coming into the MCU from Fox
implying that if Marvel does not get
more ownership of spider-man it's not
really worth their time now of course
this is coming from Sony and not from
Marvel themselves although Sony did say
there is no ill will towards Disney
however there is still a sliver of hope
as Sony CEO did say that it's a long
life implying that perhaps down the road
the webslinger could make its way back
to the MCU but unfortunately as of right
now it is official spider-man is back at
Sony and is no longer a part of the MCU
be sure to let out all your tears down
below in the comments section let me
know what you think about this do you
think Spidey will be okay in Sony's
hands and do you think that he could
possibly return to the MCU one day leave
your thoughts down below also don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero
or villain like this video and subscribe
to my channel to stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof